وهناك مخاطر متناميه باندلاع حرب اهليه
اذا طال هذا النزاع وهو يهدد بطبيعه خطيره
على دول المنطقه نحن على قناعه بان وجود
يونيتامز هو مهم اليوم اكثر من اي وقت مضى
لتنسيق استجابه الامم المتحده
للتحديات التي تواجهها الدوله السيده
الرئيس نرحب بمواصله عمل اليونيتامس من
خلال الاليه الثلاثيه لمساعده الشعب
السوداني على تخطي التحديات التي تواجهه
في هذه المرحله المحوريه نحن ندعو ايضا
الاطراف الى وقف اطلاق النار على الفور
ونحن نكرر ما جاء في بيان مجلس السلام
والامن للاتحاد الافريقي في السابع
والعشرين من مايو 2023 نشاهده على اهميته
خطه خفض التصعيد الذي اقترحها الاتحاد
الافريقي كخريطه طريق لانهاء النزاع في
السودان نعيد تاكيد على دور المحوري
للمنظمات دون الاقليم مثل الاتحاد
الافريقي والهيئه الحكوميه الدوليه
المعنيه بالتنميه الايجارات في حل هذه
الازمه ونشدد على اهميه التنسيق بين مختلف
المبادرات ان الوضع الانساني المقلق الذي
يشهده المدنيون والنازحون داخليا
واللاجئون
من الغده المجاوره يتطلب حشد الجهود
لمواجهه هذه التحديات من الملح ان يحشد
المجتمع الدولي جهوده لتمويل خطه
الاستجابه الانسانيه 2023
وخطط الاستجابه الانسانيه في البدن
المجاوره التي تستضيف عددا كبيرا من
اللاجئين السودانيين ندعو الى ضمان الوصول
بدون اي عراقيل للعميله في المجال
الانساني ونشدده على اهميه توفير المساعده
الانسانيه للسودان والدول المجاوره تماشا
مع مبادئ
ايصال المساعده الانسانيه في الختام نعيد
تاكيد على تضامننا مع الشعب السوداني في
هذه الاوقات العصيبه في تاريخ بلادهم
وشكرا
اشكر ممثله الغابون على بيانه لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات